[موسيقى]
في فرنسا تتزايد الحاجه الى اليد العامله
بشكل كبير فهناك نقص الحديد في الكثير من
المهن الخدميه والحكومه اليوم تسعى الى سد
هذه الثغره من خلال سني قوانين جديده بهدف
تسويه اوضاع بعض المهاجرين غير الشرعيه
على اراضيها للاستفاده من وجودهم وايجاد
حلولا لتوظيفهم بشكل النظامي
في الدوله الفرنسيه وضعت خطا يوجد هناك من
انواع من الاعمال العمل في البناء العمل
في المطاعم في الفنادق في التنظيف في
مساعده
كبار السن في البيوت الممرضات
والحتى السائقين الكميونات والباصات ان كل
من قم بهذا العمل
يذهب الى البروجكتير منطقه الشرطه ويقوم
ويقول انا اعمل وعندي عقد عمل
فسوف يعطونه الاقامه وهذه المبادره جيده
من الحكومه التي تتخبط
[موسيقى]
ها وزاره العمل ان غالبيه العمال
المهاجرين تشغل وظائف الشاقه في فرنسا اذا
يتعرضوا هؤلاء لضغوط كبيره في قطاع العمل
تضرهم الى خوض غمار مهن صعبه تشهد عاده
نقصا في العيد العامله
انا كنت نخدم ديميناجمون
عام ونص وانا نخدم ديميناجم بدون اوراق
معليش انا مستعد قدامك انا اديني نخدم وين
تحب وين تحب نخدم لك اخدم لك في الروقار
ندخل نخدم فيه عادي
ما عندي حتى نخدم
[موسيقى]
ان يحصل المهاجر على وظيفه في فرنسا وظيفه
واحده من اصل عشر وظائف يشغلها عامل من
اصول اجنبيه
في الصباح وايضا في فتره ما بعد الظهر
ويتطلب الوجود في اماكن مختلفه احيانا
والمهاجرون في بدايه وصولهم الى هنا
يقبلون احيانا بهذه الوظائف على عكس
الاشخاص الاخرين الذين استقروا منذ فتره
اطول والذين لديهم مستويات من التعليم
وبالتالي ايضا حظوظهم في التوظيف ليست
نفسها